the best developers don't need to
comment on their code because they write
self-describing code that is so elegant
that it reads like a haiku
the rest of us though need comments like
this dear future me please forgive me i
can't even begin to express how sorry i
am
the most useless comments though are the
ones that tell you exactly what the code
does
like this is a variable for storing a
number so you think i did good
your teammates don't care what the code
does but they do want to know why it's
breaking the build
use comments to explain why your code is
there and use industry standards like
jstoc to have comments appear in your
editor's intellisense
when your code is truly unfixable make
sure to add a warning for other
developers and give them a counter to
increment the number of hours wasted
if the project itself is inherently
flawed make sure to write out a
manifesto like this guy
my hate for pst has grown to a raging
fire that burns with the fierce passion
of a million suns psd
is not my favorite file format